[Musique]
celle qui dans le gouvernement cazeneuve
est toujours là ministre des famille de
l'enfance et des droits de la femme est
l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir
bonsoir mesdames rossignol bonsoir
madame la ministre des familles donc
merci d'être avec nous vous allez
répondre à trois grandes questions au
cours de cette émission
soutenez-vous la candidature de manuel
valls vous le dirai dans un instant à
jean francis pécresse
croyez vous que les français épargnent
auront à nouveau 21 avril à la gauche à
la gauche divisée comme jamais là vous
le dirai à lucile malandain de la sp
enfin pour évoquer vos combats notamment
celui qui vous attend demain au sénat
question sur le délit d' entrave ali vg
ce que en fait vous voulez créer une
nouvelle menace pour la liberté
d'expression c'est ce que disent vos
détracteurs vous eh bien vous voulez
vous en prendre aux sites internet et
notamment numéro vert qui cherchait
dissuader les femmes de pratiquer un
avortement mais d'abord une question
d'actualité
[Musique]
rossignol est ce que vous êtes heureuse
heureuse dans ma vie heureuse dans mon
rôle de ministre
rose est reconduite oui oui oui je suis
heureuse parce que j'aime c'est un
portefeuille j'ai un périmètre qui est
un beau un beau portefeuille ministériel
c'est à dire que s'occuper des enfants
des familles et des droits des femmes
c'est s'occuper de quasiment tout le
monde et c'est des vrais combats et
s'étaient vraie avancée pour la société
quand est ce que vous l'avez su que vous
étiez maintenant vous à passer un petit
coup de fil comment ça se passe ah non
on marque on a un coup de fil en général
quand on est devenus maintenant quand on
est promu
quand on est appelé quand on est
débarqué ça m'est pas arrivé mais j'ai
cru comprendre qu'on n'avait pas de
couteau
souvent on l'apprend à la télé dont j'ai
regardé la télévision ce matin comme
tout le monde et puis j'ai vu les deux
des trois annonces qui se sont succédé
qui remplaçait bernard cazeneuve les
changements mais j'avais un père
mutation n'ont pas d'informations
officielles n'ya pas vraisemblablement y
avait peut-être pas se poser de
questions est le choix qui est fait
c'est effectivement le choix de
remplacer le premier ministre
avec la conséquence que ça assure le
ministère de l'intérieur est ce que vous
êtes heureuse désormais vous allez vrai
pour nous oui évidemment de travailler
avec bernard cazeneuve
oui mais je travaillais déjà avec
bernard cazeneuve mais là c'est le chef
oui c'est cette chef il à moi j'aime
bien comme disait le premier ministe
précédent le chef est là pour chiffrer
et bernard cazeneuve a la capacité non
pas d'être autoritaire manuel valls
était pas non plus mais bon on lui
prêtait quand même ça change elles
n'étaient pas honorées par une femme non
pas aux tories qu'avec ses ministres
d'abord il est soutenu
il les défend des quand il était attaqué
ça s'est révélé de nombreuses fois quand
marisol touraine par exemple été
beaucoup attaqué sur le tiers payant il
l'a défendu quand ce premier ministre
ont attaqué les défendent est de nouveau
et le nouveau il allait même capacité à
être un chef d'equipe c'est-à-dire à
extraire de nous le meilleur à nous
faire bien travailler ensemble et puis
là une expérience que remarque à moi
j'ai travaillé déjà avec huile son
ministère sur les questions de
prévention de la radicalisation et
d'accompagnement des familles des jeunes
qui sont partis en syrie
d'accord est ce que ce choix de bernard
cazeneuve c'est aussi celui du
soulagement
pour françois hollande est pas se
reposer sur lui pour pendant les cinq
mois qui viennent là me fait est qu'il
ya pour se reposer tout court assez fine
il à la guerre au sommet le bras de fer
mais le quinquennat a fêté le canada
bras de fer entre le premier ministre et
président de la république mais sauf que
hier à ces dernières semaines il ya ce
qu'on a vu sur la durée c'est une très
courte période
manuel valls est un premier ministre
extrêmement loyale et protecteur aussi à
l'égard du président de la république et
le schéma qu'avait manuel valls chaque
foyer a travaillé c'était de permettre à
françois hollande est de nouveau
candidat manuel valls n'avait vraiment
oui vraiment reparler plus tard il n'y a
pas d'arrière pensée et donc jeu pour
revenir à la question vous osiez n'est
un instant oui je pense que le choix du
président la république de nommer
bernard cazeneuve comme premier ministre
j'appelle ces choix de se reposer je
pense que c'est un choix qui est celui
d'après la république qui est toujours
d'abord et avant tout préoccupés des
questions de sécurité
la menace terroriste n'a pas diminué
avec les événements politiques que nous
connaissons il n'y a pas de lien entre
les deux elle est toujours présente et
le président de la république est
totalement engagée sur ce sujet laurent
social vous vous reste en tous les cas
en première ligne sur plusieurs sujets
qui par ailleurs vous tiennent à coeur
on va en parler donc au cours de cette
émission mais d'abord on accueille jean
francis pécresse le directeur de la
rédaction de radio classique qui vient
vous poser une autre question politique
on sort enfin son histoire michel
concevoir laurent soir rossignol alors
depuis hier soir manuel valls est donc
candidat à la primaire du ps de la
gauche du ps
est ce que vous le soutiendrez ce que
vous voterez pour lui je vais voter pour
manuel valls et je soutiendrai parce que
dans cette primaire est ensuite dans
l'élection présidentielle je n'imagine
pas que le débat ait lieu devant les
français entre des candidats à la prison
de la république qui tous soit en jambes
soient piétine
ce quinquennat est le bilan que nous
portons et je crois que le bilan que
nous avons bien sûr il y à des
frustrations
bien sûr il y a des résultats qui ont
été longs à venir
et il ya aussi des succès et des choses
très fier ou en particulier dans mon
secteur je pourrais vous parler de mes
sujet de fierté est donc bien entendu il
est indispensable que à mon sens le
candidat qui représentera le parti
socialiste et la gauche
plus largement dans cette élection
présidentielle soit aussi porteur du
bilan je crois que les français n'y
comprendraient rien s'ils n'avaient
personne
chaque gouverner cinq ans et elle ne
peut pas être absente du débat
deux à la fois du bilan mais aussi du
projet donc si je vous comprends bien
vous voterez valser voulu soutiendrez
parce qu'il défendra bien le bilan de
françois hollande
mais c'est le sien au cices notre bilan
collectif et je viens sur ses amis leur
collectif le bilan de françois hollande
c'est le bilan d'une majorité
parlementaire est également stable c'est
un bilan que nous portons tous et c'est
un bilan qui a suffisamment d'avancé sur
le plan social
je prends parler si vous voulez de ce
qu'on a fait en matière d'accès à la
retraite des carrières longues de
protection sociale nous avons consolidé
sur matière d'éducation le bilan en
matière de politique familiale en
matière d'égalité femmes hommes en
matière de justice en matière de
transparence
tous ces éléments du bilan ils ont
vocation à être présents parce qu'ils
ont vocation est défendue pas simplement
pour défendre votre bilan mais pour
défendre ce qu'ils à ce que ce bilan
incarne pour les français s'il est
tellement bon ce bilan pourquoi au fond
françois hollande ni n'est pas allé même
je ne vous dis pas que ce bilan est
tellement bon je ne vous dis pas ça
junique ce bilan et est à défendre à ses
deux derniers départs
parce que le chef parce que le président
de la république a constaté qu'il y
avait donc d'abord il a été victime
pendant depuis 2012 d'une fixation d'une
crispation et d'une de tak tak sur sa
personne qui ont commencé très
rapidement il ya probablement toujours
dans la vème république une dimension
personnelle et une dimension collective
et dans la dimension personnelle du
président de la république a évalué et
d'ailleurs il l'a dit dans le discours
qu'il a prononcé quand il annonce aux
français qu'il ne se représenterait pas
que dans l'intérêt de de nous tous ils
avaient décidé de renoncer à se
présenter parce qu'il a peut-être fait
lui aussi des erreurs ou des fautes est
ce que ce livre de confidences à n'a pas
été pour vous en particulier une sorte
de goutte d'eau qui a fait déborder le
vase et qui a fait qu'à un moment donné
vous avez fait le choix du candidat
valls plutôt du candidat hollande tout
et je pense qu'il serait malvenu
désagréments inutilement désagréable et
que ça relèverait de l'acharnement
maintenant que françois hollande a
décidé de nouveaux candidats de
continuer à discuter par de la même
façon dont nous discutions
il ya trois semaines ou un mois sur sa
place dans le bilan du quinquennat
lecture lisez le livre sur des éléments
qui ont effectivement abandonné plus
obturer la perception collective du
bilan est-ce que la candidature de
manuel valls peut être une règle une
candidature de réconciliation comme il
l'a dit hier soir et ce qu'il vous
paraît être à l'épicentre du ps c'est
une bonne question
ce qui est intéressant d'observer
aujourd'hui sur cette question de
l'épicentre est venu le mot clé du débat
politique depuis quelques temps le coeur
du ps mais voilà mais non mais c'était
le moins puissante et juste
d'abord prendre une remarque tu rentres
fillon est l'épicentre de la droite
c'est à dire que c'est apprendre à la
droite que je qualifierais de dur sur
deux points économique dure sur le plan
social et conservatrice sur le plan de
2h30 alors le mot moeurs sultan sociétal
le mot meurt c'est un petit connotation
à l'ancienne vous avez des gens n'est
pas la seule c'est cool voilà ça et 200
le plan sociétal
pour autant il faut d'abord se garder
d'avoir un raisonnement en miroir
totalement mécanique qui consistera
pensé que puisque l'épicentre de la
droite est très à droite
l'épicentre de la gauche serait
forcément très à gauche
le problème que nous avons et c'est
d'ailleurs une des raisons de la
diversité et de la division aujourd'hui
dé gauche c'est que l'épicentre de la
gauche on ne sait pas exactement où il
est et je ne crois pas qu'il soit ni une
ni d'un côté quelque part entre jean luc
mélenchon et philippe poutou ni de
l'autre côté quelque part entre emmanuel
macron et françois bayrou ce que
d'ailleurs c'est plus la gauche et
indique emmanuel macron n'est pas très
très loin là de deux personnes que vous
venez de citer deux français deux
emmanuel macron je pensais à lui non
mais moi je sais ce que je veux dire
c'est que c'est ce que je veux
simplement dire que c'est un des sujets
sait où est l'épicentre de la gauche et
le défi
la candidature manuel valls c'est
justement de construire l'épicentre
c'est de donner à la gauche
le ce point qui n'est pas un point de
compromis mais qui est un point en
construction les clés parce que des
questions n'ont pas été will régler mais
manuel valls est quand même l'homme de
la loi travail par exemple c'est celui
qui a été pour la déchéance est ce que
c'est parce que là dans cette gauche là
vous vous reconnaissez est-ce que c'est
dans ce ps là vous vous reconnaissez
vous c'est possible après ces
différentes fractures au sein de
l'appareil fin au sein de votre parti de
réconcilier ce que lui-même appelé hier
de deux gauches irréconciliables et même
manuel valls apporter toutes les
réformes de du canada du quinquennat de
manière très solidaire et extrêmement
protectrice à l'égard du président de la
république sur la déchéance de
nationalité
je ne sais pas jusqu'à quand il a été
favorable j'avais cru comprendre que
tout le monde devait douter quand même
assez vite de la pertinence et le
président de la république d'ailleurs là
encore peut être pas utile d'y revenir a
dit que c'était un c'était son regret
dans ce quinquennat la déchéance de
nationalité la loi travail elle a été
portée par le premier ministre est aussi
président de la république nous la belle
collecte a été porté collectivement je
pense que manuel valls a beaucoup agi
pour protéger président de la république
pendant ce quinquennat c'est à dire que
il a joué le rôle de premier ministre
adjoint et ministre et celui qui va en
avant qui prend les coups le souvent
également et qui portent et aujourd'hui
manuel valls il est en situation de
construire justement ce nouvel épicentre
alors pour vendre il était entré juste
une chose aujourd'hui
est ce que manuel valls est aujourd'hui
à l'épicentre de la gauche je ne sais
pas et nous n'avons rien pour le dire
est ce que manuel valls peut engager une
dynamique qui lui permettent à la fin de
la primaire d'avoir que la gauche ce
soir rassembler de nouveau autour d'un
axe fort oui je le crois alors c'est mal
partis quand même jour pour vous tout de
suite d'écoutés oui leur a transmis au
malawi à écouter les premières réactions
et un soir dans la foulée de sa
candidature à gauche c'est une levée de
boucliers quelle que soit la sincérité
des intentions du
candidat manuel valls ses intentions de
candidats contredisent ces actes de
premier ministre et je pense que sa
candidature est sans doute la plus
clivante qu'ils soient aujourd'hui au
parti socialiste a raison des choix
qu'il a fait très présente dans ce tir
un candidat qui représente le coeur des
valeurs du parti socialiste n'est pas
évident manuel valls candidat a prononcé
un discours d'opposant à sa propre
politique
il est maintenant le premier défenseur
de l'unité de la gauche alors qu'il a
théorisé les gauches irréconciliables
quel est donc le manuel valls qui s'est
exprimé ce soir celui qui gouverne ou
celui qui candidatent du figaro ce matin
rien surprenant et dans son pour son
éditorial manuel valls contre val ce
manuel est ce que vous êtes et ce que
vous reconnaissez quand même une forme
de contradiction entre son discours
d'hier soir et ce qu'il tenait comme
discours quand il était premier ministre
mais son discours n'a pas bien vu le
chemin qu'il avait voulu tracer hier il
dit je veux trouver reposer un chemin
c'est quoi ce chômage et on t'a vu le
discours d'hier soir c'est un discours
de candidat
ce n'est plus simplement discours du
premier ministre mais dit deux choses il
est pourri dit d'abord que il portera le
bilan et c'est important j'ai évoqué il
ya déjà un instant qu'il portera le
bilan est que il le met dans son ce
chemin tout ce qui a été en même temps
sont une partie de son identité
c'est à dire la laïcité l'égalité la
fraternité et ils se situent ils se
situent dans une candidature
républicaine républicaine et sociale
c'est ça c'est ça le chemin de la
candidature de manuel valls aujourd'hui
alors j'entends bien ce que disent les
autres candidats à la primaire va tout
le monde dit ça en républicaine et
sociale cepas suis pas d'abord la
question de la laïcité on en parle tout
à l'heure j'imagine quand on prendra
diverger mais la question de
républicaine il suffit pas de le dire
encore faut-il le
le prouver mais surtout encore faut-il
avoir un programme qui soit adaptée à ça
quand françois fillon nous dit qu'à la
fois il veut réserver la sécurité
sociale aux gens qui sont atteints
d'affections de longue durée ou qu'il
veut supprimer cinq cent mille
fonctionnaires
c'est peut-être ils peuvent toujours
dire qu'il est républicain une fois
qu'elle ait dit ça mais c'est la
première fois depuis ce que j'observe la
politique de prêt ça fait quand même
quelques années que je vois un candidat
qui est aussi franchement nettement en
rupture avec ce qui constitue l'histoire
collective et entre autres et en
particulier le programme du consensuel
la résistance
c'est la première fois que je vois un
candidat qui dit voilà je veux en finir
avec la sécurité sociale en france parce
que ce qu'a dit françois fillon c'est
jose on en finit avec la sécurité
sociale c'est un tout petit peu résumé
quand même non à écouter quand on
commence à dire j'avais entendu ça
vraiment quand on commence avec des
millions d'ursa jeu quand on commence à
dire que la sécurité sociale sera
réservé à ceux qui sont atteints de
longue maladie à ceux qui ont des
maladies lourdes et que pour tout le
reste ce sera renvoyé vers les
assurances privées ou les mutuelles sont
d'ailleurs nous préciser ces gîtes des
mutuelles du code de la mutualité où des
mutuelles du code des assurances
là on est dans une véritable de rupture
sur le principe même de la sécurité
sociale c'est à dire la solidarité sur
la prise en charge globale de la maladie
et surtout cette idée qui sous-tendait
l'assurance maladie qui est que c'est en
soignant tous les jours
deux des petites maladies qu'on a qu'on
se prémunit ce contrôle est grave mais
loin des modifications sur d'autres
études puisque bernard accoyer
aujourd'hui même un grand soutien de
françois fillon dit qu' il faudra
apporter des éclaircissements et lui est
opposé à ce qui est annoncé en matière d
étatisation de la sécu a donc le
discours va évoluer le projet aussi de
ce côté là ce serait bien que françois
fillon n'est pas un discours pour gagner
et maire de la droite un autre discours
ensuite avec des gens qui le soutiennent
parce que lui aussi si l'alternance se
produisait s'ils gagnent élection
présidentielle aurait quand même une
majorité qui peut être accru est ce
qu'il a dit pendant la primaire d'autant
plus que je pense que ce qu'il a dit
pendant la primaire correspond
exactement à ce qu'ils pensent merci
beaucoup 0,6
lucile malandain de l' effet arrive
désormais pour la deuxième partie de
l'épreuve de vérité
l'épreuve de vérité avec life et bonsoir
de ses concerts michel oncins mana
rossignol alors croyez vous dans la
situation actuelle tels que ça se
présente pour la présidentielle 2017 que
les français aient devons épargner un
nouveau 21 avril à la gauche et au prij
incidemment qui aurait volé ma réponse
divisée comme divisée comme comme jamais
même de ne presque encore plus divisés
en 2002 vous pourrez dire si on compte
le nombre de candidats qui se présentent
à la terre de la primaire et or de la
primaire voilà on est la différence avec
2002 c'est qu'en 2002 il y avait pas de
primaire
on est dans un processus différentes
2002 et puis ces produits 2002 qu'elle
essaie quand même à la fois des
blessures et des souvenirs à ceux qui y
ont participé
ou qu'ils ont vécu aujourd'hui nous
avons une primaire la primaire elle a
aussi pour vocation si nous la
réussissons cette primaire de permettre
à la gauche de construire un
rassemblement et je suis comme michel
grossiord je pense que ce serait bien
que les français épargnent pas
simplement à la gauche mais c'est par
nous mêmes et par nos pays un nouveau
21-avril surtout qu' il n'est pas dit
que ce set nous ce nouveau côté avril
soit le même à l'abri d'un certain point
de vue ça commence mal et ça finit bien
si j'ose dire le premier tour comme adam
2e tour le premier tour est le premier
tour est un désastre deuxième tour se
finit par la victoire de jacques chirac
à laquelle j'aime aussi contre la plus
80% de la plus 80 % des voix euh là les
risques sont différents
françois fillon n'est pas jacques chirac
d'eni dans son programme ni dans son
identité ni dans la partie de la droite
à laquelle ils se rattachent ni dans la
droite qui le porte
et s'il a écouté on a beaucoup de
diaboliser dans le passé jacques chirac
c'est ce que vous faites aujourd'hui
avec françois fillon n'ont écouté
jacques chirac a toujours eu ce nom je
crois que c'est pas deux personnalités
identique j'ai pas se dire qu'on est moi
je me souviens de quelques petites
phrases de jacques chirac
souvenez vous il y avait fait chaud
chirac je suis une petite phrase de
jacques chirac mais en en 2002 mais dans
une saison connaît déjà si on a vu
chirac
déjà président de la république on sait
que jacques chirac est somme toute dans
une espèce de tradition d'une droite qui
ça continue de s'inspirer du compromis
gaulliste voilà pour la fiction c'est
différent parce que s'ils s'obstinent à
faire la campagne qu'il a fait dans la
primaire à dire ce qu'il dit en
particulier en termes de modèle social
s'ils s'obstinent à vouloir être le
margaret thatcher de la france un
certain point de vue et à être aussi le
conservateur parmi les conservateurs
je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils créent les
conditions pour que le deuxième tour en
2017 soit aussi facile que l'a été celui
de jacques chirac mais là vous vous
jouerez du principe déjà que la gauche
et éliminer 90 après je continue on est
dans l'hypothèse où c'est la gauche qui
est devant qui est face à marine le pen
au deuxième tour
je ne suis pas sûr non plus que le
discours de la droite d'aujourd'hui
favorise le rassemblement républicain au
deuxième tour contre marine le pen
donc je ne vois qu'une solution pour
nous prémunir de marine le pen en 2017
c'est un deuxième tour droite gauche
bon voilà celui là et qui d'ailleurs
ressemble bien plus et correspond bien
davantage au pays qu'un autre type de
deuxième tour dans lequel le front
national seraient présents merci laisser
troisième partie de l'épreuve de vérité
maintenant avec mais qu'elle amène le
public sénat qui arrive on va évoquer le
rossignol vos combats comme ministre
notamment des droits de la femme
ministre des droits des femmes michel
allons avec le délit d' entrave
numérique il sera donc examinée demain
au sénat
portez-vous atteinte à la liberté
d'expression comme on l'entend depuis
une semaine peut-être on va reprendre
qu'est ce que le délit d' entrave ni sur
les végétaux répond à vos questions
j'ai pas l'habitude de d'esquiver les
questions non mais pour nos spectateurs
aujourd'hui ce que nous observons c'est
qu' il existe des sites internet
extrêmement actifs qui sont entre les
deux qui sont les outils de propagande
des associations anti ivg de toutes
celles et ceux qui n'ont jamais renoncé
dans leur hostilité à nouveau l ivg et
qui ont qui se sont installés sur un
créneau qui est celui de l'apparence de
la neutralité l'apparence de
l'information pour attirer des femmes
qui cherchent des informations santé
publique ou légal
par exemple je veux faire je peux
pratiquer une ivg quels sont les délais
quelles sont les techniques
à qui dois je m'adresser est-ce que
c'est remboursé les fans que georges
aussi une écoute psychologique parfois
des femmes qui cherchent une écoute
psychologique aussi parfois mais elle la
trouveront dans le parcours médical
il y a deux rendez-vous avec un médecin
et le médecin avec l'équipe médicale qui
va pratiquer les ivg va leur apporter
aussi c'était coup psychologique elle
est déjà là les coûts de psychologique
et est donc ces femmes sont attirées sur
ces sites elles pensent qu'elles
viennent d'entrer sur un site
d'information elle se retrouve au
téléphone avec des gens qui est des
écoutantes qui vont électriser dorian
pas forcément que sur internet ont
maintenant deux sont les fameux numéro
vert et vous si vous si vous lisez un
peu toutes les enquêtes qui ont été
faites à la fois par vos collègues mais
aussi par des associations auprès de ses
numéros verts on y décline un tissu de
sottises centre médical scientifique du
style les vg vous rend stérile toutes
les femmes qui ont fait une qui ont que
rocco une progression également assisté
ont toutes une ivg avant et tous vos
enfants sont traumatisés y compris ceux
qui naîtrait après libéré et au bout du
compte il ya ces cétacés que
conversations téléphoniques ont comme
finalité de faire douter la femme de sa
décision et de lui faire perdre
michel finissent par d'espacer les
délais donc c'est à ça que nous nous
sommes attaqués d'abord par la méthode
du référencement certes nous avons un
sit in est un site gouvernemental ivg
point gouv.fr qui donnent des
informations fiables objectives et de
nature ne totalement nous dit aux
français
allez voir ce site de référence oui mais
pas sur internet ça ce que vous dit non
jeudi elle ce site est un site internet
mais en réalité quand une femme veut des
informations elle va taper enceinte a va
taper avortement est la table et elle a
un risque en fonction de la halle de
l'aléatoire les le référencement des
sites vous pouvez faire monter un site
de référencement
et puis il suffit que x mots-clés dit
qu'ils soient rentrés sur la page où la
page du mode deux nouveaux temps de
recherche voilà et le site officiel va
redescendre on est sûr que quelque part
vous avez perdu cette bataille
d'internet on a perdu ses intérêts vous
aussi les jours certes internet entre
l'information fiable
vérifiez sûr c'est que vous donnez et le
tissu de mensonges complotistes qui
circulent sur internet
vous avez peut-être aussi un peu perdu
la bataille mais vous êtes gros temps
n'avait pas cessé de l'amener et vous
avez pas renoncé et moi non deux comme
vous et moi non plus je n'ai alors non
voilées question parce que je ne sais ce
qui est insupportable dans cette affaire
c'est qu'elle part du présupposé qu'une
femme qui a décidé de faire une ivg est
une femme qui n'a pas réfléchi est une
femme qui a pris une décision légère et
qu'il faudrait la faire réfléchir
or quand une femme a décidé faire une
ivg croyez moi qu'elle a réfléchi écouté
par exemple bruno retailleau à quel
patron des sénateurs les républicains et
qui a très mal pris le fait d'être
accusée en fait de céder au lobby catho
ce que vous l'avez dit il répond alors
on écoute tu stupide je lui réponds une
chose quand la gauche est en situation
d'échec
elle nous ressort ses vieilles
caricature ces vieilles lunes la loi
veil n'est pas remise en cause c'est un
oui ce qui est un vrai sujet si la
liberté d'expression ce qui est un vrai
sujet pour un acte de cette gravité là
et que personne ne remet en cause en
termes je veux dire de liberté de chaque
femme a décidé évidemment
c'est que le gouvernement veuille
diviser les français là où franchement
on me répond un signal à bordeaux et à
ce jeu je veux bien admettre que bruno
retailleau à un sujet sur les pépins
discrétion mais là aussi un sujet sur
les vg bruno retailleau était quand même
auparavant un des plus proches adjoints
politique de philippe de villiers
il a été candidat du mpf formation
politique qui n'a jamais caché sa
farouche hostilité à la loi veil et à la
liberté de l'avortement
bruno retailleau d'ailleurs comme
françois fillon n'a voté aucune des lois
de mise en oeuvre de la loi veil et
d'amélioration de la loi veil
il a été il a saisi le conseil
constitutionnel lorsque nous avons
supprimé la condition de détresse
jusqu'à la grille prévoyait que les
femmes doivent rapporter la preuve d'une
condition de détresse ont considéré que
femmes savent ce qu'elles font
elles n'ont pas rapporté la preuve de
pourquoi elles font une ivg
c'est leur vie renault retail on faisait
partie des sénateurs qui avaient saisi
les conséquences ionel je pense que
bruno retailleau n'a jamais manifesté
dans sa jeunesse pour la dépénalisation
du vg et qu'on n'a pas été dans les
mêmes mouvements ce sens les années de
115 me dire quoi
je pense que je les avais cru mais alors
là je pense qu'ils sont partis je pense
qu'il fait partie d'un courant de pensée
qui en vend des corpos et le prendre
penser de ce niveau historiquement suite
philippe dallier toulouse plus là non
plus d'accord baisse qu'auront sur des
questions aussi central dans la dans la
pensée d'un individu que le rapport à
l'hiver et d'ailleurs comme il le dit
fais partie de ces gens qui disent c'est
un acte d'une extrême gravité
la gravité des ivg moi je pense que
l'hiver est n'est pas un acte anodin
non mais qu'il faut cesser de dire aux
femmes qu à chaque fois qu elle soit ils
font quelque chose d'excitant allemande
la météo ce que je veux dire que cécile
sujet c'est la liberté d'expression ont
probablement trouvé le moyen de se
mettre d'accord mais si le sujet comme
je l'aï entendu à l'assemblée nationale
la semaine dernière parce qu'il y avait
les bruno retailleau de l'assemblée
nationale qui était dans l'hémicycle
petite anecdote il était onze députés
des républicains tous ceux qui étaient
là étaient ceux qui n'avaient pas signé
qui n'avaient pas voté la résolution sur
ivg droit fondamental donc il était
bienvenu quand même sur l'île et g et
pas sur la liberté d'expression et il y
avait dans toute la journée j'ai entendu
dix hommes nous parler des femmes et dvg
avec une tranquille assurance une
tranquille et ans qui n'avait pas l'air
de les contrarier
donc c'est bruno retailleau veut bien
nous dire qu'il ne soutient pas ces
sites parce qu'on fonde la sphère il est
là c est ce qu on soutient ou non ces
sites d'accord vous serrer la main ou
des toqués au niveau d'un bourg quand je
crois en lui serrant la main une somme
courtois l'un et l'autre je pense qu on
peut travailler alors qu'on ne sait rien
mais que chaque n'est que chacun dise
quelle est sa position s'il n'y a pas
d'accord de l'eau vous repasserez encore
une fois par le sénat
une troisième fois côté ci a pas
d'accord demain il y aura une commission
mixte paritaire et l'assemblée aura le
dernier mot et ensuite nous reprendrons
la procédure pas la procédure de navette
voilà c'est un texte c'est une
proposition doit comme les autres et
soumises à la même procédure de ne pas
s'asseoir coeur politique
on assiste à une nouvelle passe d'armes
entre marine et sa nièce vous avez vu
marion maréchal qui elle voudrait
revenir sur le remboursement intégral il
limité de lits vgc une passe d'armes ou
bien c'est une répartition des rôles
je ne sais pas je suis pas experte de la
famille le pen ce que je sais c'est que
on peut tout à la fois affirmer affirmé
qu'on ne touchera pas la loi veil et
coupé les moyens de l'accès à libé g et
avoir le même résultat en termes
d'inégalités d'accès et de difficultés
d'accès léger que si on touche à la loi
veil et c'est de cela je suis
extrêmement préoccupé pour les mois et
les années à venir dans le disque en
date d'aujourd'hui et elle l'a ramené au
pouvoir pour les cinq mois qui viennent
vous avez encore
travailler sur le sexisme et sur
l'égalité salariale laurence rossignol
merci d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui
merci michael bonsoir à tous à la
semaine prochaine